Hey, is this right, 'cause you're so busy,
you're doing so many
things, and I do wanna,
I mean between "Brooklyn
Nine-Nine" and this terrific movie,
which I wanna talk to you about,
which is, I'm gonna say this,
I love this film, I really do.
And it's one of my favorite
movies that I've seen
during this whole quarantine.
And I'm watching classics
like "Lawrence of Arabia"
and, you know, "Citizen Kane".
I loved everything about it.
It's a great story, the
performances are incredible,
and it was funny and
it was also very sweet.
And then I noticed that you're
an executive producer in the movie,
and I thought that must be
kind of cool to be in the film,
but also be executive producing
it, or is it difficult?
It's a lot of work, you know,
it was a small movie with a small budget,
but the pluses for me
outweigh the minuses.
And a big part of that for me as an actor
is I can kind of just try stuff out
and then when I watch the
edit and feel humiliated,
I can just demand, as a producer,
that it be cut, you know?
(Conan laughs)
So, it's kind of like, it's a chill vibe
for me to bring to the table (laughs).
Yeah, yeah.
(Conan laughs)
But, you know, that's kind of how
I've been rolling the last few years.
It's kind of, I call it
the Andre Braugher rule,
you know, where I'm a
producer on Brooklyn too,
where I'm like, just
surround me with good actors
and then we'll get in the edit.
And then anytime I suck, we'll
just cut to the good actor.
The cast is terrific-
They really are, yeah.
In this movie.
You guys all seem to work out,
and then you got the incredible
J.K. Simmons to be in this.
And I mean, the man's won an Oscar.
Ahnd he's Jonah Jameson.
And he's also Jonah Jameson
in the Spider-Man series.
Yeah, I would try to get him to talk to me
as Jonah Jameson a lot and be like,
"Pretend I'm Peter Parker
and be Jonah Jameson."
And he'd be like,
"What, no, I'm not gonna do that."
(Conan laughs)
And I'd be like, "Do my outgoing voicemail
as Jonah Jameson."
And be like, "I need
pictures of Spider-Man."
(Conan laughs)
And he's like, "I'm not gonna do that.
"Get out of my trailer."
(both laugh)
You just sound like not a
good executive producer.
I was like, "Yeah, I'm
a producer,you have to!"
(both laugh)
Or you're fired!
We have a clip here.
Tell us what's happening in this clip
in case anyone doesn't know.
This is early on in the film and yes,
I did use the word film, thank you.
It was at Sundance, big deal for me.
It's early on in the film.
(both laugh)
You have a little gas?
Did you have a little gas there?
(both clearing their throats)
Sorry, this is one of
my daughter's hair clips
just nervously picking it up.
Yes, early on in the film,
and you don't yet know unless
you watched the trailer
that my character has been
reliving the same day,
many times.
And I'm courting Cristin
Milioti's character, Sarah,
and sort of gliding through the wedding
and doing some dancing.
Let's take a look at this
clip from Palm Springs.
Oh yeah.
("Megatron Man")
And we're gonna show it.
(both laugh)
You know what's awkward about
these interviews that we do?
Is that when you come on the real show,
we then show to the clip
and it's a really good clip
and the audience would like
it then they would applaud
and we'd come back from it.
But when we shoot this,
we add the clip later on.
So, you didn't see the clip
and I didn't see the clip.
We both know what the clip is.
Should we...
But in this moment, it's so fake.
It's so fake I go "Let's take a look."
And then it's just you
and me going (sighs).
And then I go, "wow, that was great!"
But we didn't just see anything.
We didn't see.
Can we pretend like the
clip just ended again
and then you guys can put in applause
and we can do the like normal
thing and I will-
Yes, let's do that.
I'll take a sip of my water
like it just came out of the clip.
Let's take a look at this
clip from Palm Springs.
("Megatron Man")
(audience applauding)
We're back.
Wow!
I mean, it's a fun movie.
(both laugh)
I miss that stuff.
Me too!
I miss those little things, when is it?
I don't know.
You're a smart guy and
you're behind the scenes
in the business.
When do you think people
get back to acting
and making things again?
That's a tough one
How's it gonna work?
I have a feeling like it can
go one of two ways, right?
We will get it under control
when there's a vaccine.
Or we come up with some great protocol
that actually feels safe
or, and hear me out,
everything goes mocap, motion capture.
And we all get like
"Ready Player One" style,
mocap rigs in our homes.
And you can audition this way
and then actually shoot this way.
It's like Avatar style, but
it's like in your real pie.
So, you can even see in their own home,
Robert Camillo in his home
wearing a motion capture suit,
you're in your home.
Yeah.
And like "Ready Player
One", who with a diaper
'cause you don't wanna
waste time by leaving set.
So that's also from "Ready Player One".
The book, not for all you,
posers who just like saw the movie.
And they cut out the diaper
thing and pretty (mumbles).
Also the virtual sex, they cut out,
such a sellout Spielberg.
Unbelievable.
Anyway, but yeah, I think
if you could get like
a really good mocap rig and
like a little blue screen
or green screen room in your house.
Right.
With one of those 360
cameras and a diaper,
a big old diaper.
Yeah.
Like a big like multiple trips diaper.
Wait, so you'd be using the
diaper over and over again
without changing it?
Yeah, so you can just shoot for days,
like in "Ready Player One", the book.
Not the movie, which was a sellout?
(beep) that.
Okay.
I did like the movie though.
I did like the movie.
Yeah
That was a good move.
You still got to be in the business.